[Music]
on this Monday night the pause in
fighting in Gaza extended for two more
days relief as more hostages are freed
we want all hostages back home now and
how Hamas could benefit from 6 days of
calm a doctor who spent weeks in Gaza
trying to save lives more areas were
just completely completely pulverized
what he witnessed and what he wants the
world to know another deadly case of sex
tortion the plea from the parents of
this 12-year-old BC boy to talk about
online
Predators plus from air guitar to
arguing the animals putting the wild in
Wildlife global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us it is one Israeli family says
a little light in the darkness 11 more
hostage hostages held in Gaza are free
tonight transferred from their Hamas
captors to the hands of the Red Cross
including two mothers two three-year-old
Twins and seven other children their
fathers it's believed remain hostage as
part of that deal 33 Palestinian
civilians detained by Israel have been
released in the West Bank this 4-day
pause in fighting has held and tonight
there is word it will now be extended
for two more days though Israel's
defense minister said tonight any
further negotiations with Hamas will
take place under Israeli fire Eric
Sorenson begins our coverage
tonight Monday night in the West Bank a
Red Cross bus and Israeli security
Personnel prepared for the release of 33
more Palestinian prisoners from Gaza
Hamas video shows the transfer of what's
believed to be 11 more hostages among
them twin three-year-old girls taken
from a kibutz and now Qatari and
Egyptian negotiators are credited with
getting an agreement for a two-day
extension so more hostages and prisoners
can be
exchanged they are heart tugging moments
children reunited with their parents in
Israel and in this Palestinian home a
father hugs his two sons it is the one
major development in the conflict that
finds substantial support on both sides
in Gaza where they wait in line for
hours just for flower they are desperate
for the pause in fighting not just to be
extended but made
permanent we don't want war at all says
this woman in
Gaza a permanent truce says this woman
people want to go back to their
lives in Tel Aviv Israelis demanding
that hostages be the priority also back
a ceasefire extension whatever it takes
and as long as we keep on getting them
back home I want the ceasefire to
continue and I want to do whatever is
needed to have all of them back home US
President Biden welcomed a longer ceas
fire stating he remains deeply engaged
to ensure that this deal can continue to
deliver
results Prim Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
says Israel's goals Remain the release
of hostages and the elimination of Hamas
still the US and Israel fear that Hamas
is using this time to reorganize and
rearm this is a calculated risk that
prime minister Netanyahu and his War
cabinet are willing to take in order to
get those hostages out it's believed the
ceasefire cannot and will not last
Israel's defense minister to return to
fighting within days and throughout Gaza
eventually there's only so many hostages
that Hamas can trade away and then at
that point the Israelis have already
given their orders to resume major
combat operations it's also not clear
Hamas would release all the hostages and
lose the negotiating leverage they
currently have but for now a brief
respit extended two days and welcomed by
many on both sides Eric senson Global
News the anguish of those waiting for
word on their loved ones for weeks now
was impossible to imagine the families
of those who have their relatives back
are not celebrating it's too early when
so many others are still captive but
there is at least some relief Mike drle
has the stories of some of the families
reunited no words were needed Mayan Zen
hugging her two girls ages 15 and 8
after their release from captivity is
enough for 51 days all she had was hope
and a few photos video that showed Ella
and daphna were still alive but now it's
been so long I'm starting
to lose it again for his part Avi brooch
never stopped talking he' set up outside
the Israeli defense Ministry with a sign
reading my family is in Gaza they're now
back The Angst on his face replaced with
relief now that he can touch his wife
and three children again and then
there's four-year-old Abigail whose
parents were killed on October 7th 7th
she fled to a neighbor's home for safety
only to be captured by Hamas today she's
all smiles in the arms of her
relatives wow mon it was wow I couldn't
believe it until I saw her says her
grandfather the relief in his voice
tinge with sadness at the road before
her in the West Bank newly released
prisoners were carried on shoulders
through the streets the unbridled Joy of
Freedom interrupted only by a mother
needing to touch her son KH Z
[Music]
again celebration for Palestinians
relief for Israelis the politics of what
brought them to these moments set aside
however briefly for a little dose of
humanity Mike jlay Global News
Toronto the ferocity of the bombing the
number of wounded in such a short period
that just is larger than the the scale
of anything that I'd seen because of the
siege because of the number of wounded
the health system is going to collapse
that is Dr Hassan abua a British
Palestinian surgeon who I spoke to from
Gaza in mid October he arrived there
October 9th to help in gaza's hospitals
and he worked non-stop he is back in
London now and wants the world to know
what he witnessed Crystal ganing spoke
with him in a warning the images are
distressing a shanty town for internal
displaced people is how Dr gazan abua
describes what used to be gaza's main
hospital it was one of several
facilities where Dr abua spent weeks
trying to help injured Palestinians as
the war progressed more areas were just
completely completely pulverized really
unrecognizable parts of Gaza that I'd
seen multiple times became completely
unrecognizable also unrecognizable Dr
Abu tells Global News the standard of
care he and others were forced to
utilize supplies ran out but the injured
kept coming as did those seeking safety
this is what he told global news on
October 15th while at alifa hospital and
with the hygiene and with the
unseasonably warm weather this is a
typhus or chera epidemic waiting to
happen he recalls wounds infected with
fly larva and worms and how out of
desperation
he turned to a shocking Quick Fix did
you go buy dishwashing liquid and
vinegar I just bought some hand soap but
we were just going through them so much
that I went out and just both locally
manufactured dishwasher uh soap uh uh uh
U and as we started seeing more and more
infected wounds uh I started buying uh
bottles of vinegar to clean and
disinfect infected uh wounds because we
just didn't have what what we needed
anymore and every day you felt that you
were sinking further and further into
this Quicks sand I confession from a
surgeon who worked in 12 War zones in
the Middle East including Iraq and
Yemen he fears Gaza is being turned into
what he calls an uninhabitable death
World saying the majority of victims he
saw were women and children if we end up
from this war living in a world where
it's okay to do this then that world
will become a a a a dangerous place the
International Center of justice for
Palestinians says it has launched a war
crimes investigation unit and is
gathering evidence against Israeli
officials and anyone promoting or
encouraging violations of international
laws the organization says Dr Abu Sitta
will be meeting with British law
officials to share what he's witnessed
Donna all right crystal ganing in London
thanks Elon Musk who faced a backlash
after agreeing with an anti-semitic post
on his social media site went to Israel
today he met prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and visited places Hamas
attacked on October
7th the two men didn't publicly discuss
anti-Semitism but Israel did reach a
deal to deploy musk's starlink
satellites in Israel and Gaza for use by
internationally recognized a
organizations but only with the approval
of the Israeli government in Vermont a
48-year-old man has been charged with
three counts of attempted murder after
three young men of Palestinian descent
were shot on the street of a small City
investigators are still working to
determine if it was a hate crime which
as Jackson prco reports are on the rise
in the
US this suspected Act of hate unfolded
in a quiet corner of Vermont where three
Palestinian students wearing cfas were
attacked by a man with a gun he stepped
off a porch and produced a firearm and
began discharging that firearm the men
were all seriously wounded but are
expected to survive please not there
police quickly arrested the suspect
48-year-old Jason Eaton Mr Eaton enters
he pleaded not guilty to three counts of
attempted murder one of the victims
hasham awartani was from romala in the
Israeli controlled West Bank my husband
is devastated because he sent my hus my
son to the states for an education and
he thought it would be safe though
prosecutors suspect this was a hate
crime they can't yet be certain since
October 7th both Muslim and Jewish
Americans have reported a dramatic rise
in hate incidents including the murder
of a six-year-old Palestinian Boy near
Chicago people are changing their
behaviors uh they're changing the way
they look and the way they dress uh
because they are seeing so many other
people being on the receiving end of
attacks Federal officials have
repeatedly warned the conflict in the
Middle East has raised the risk of
terrorism and targeted violence on
American soil there is understandable
fear in communities across the country
as the investigation unfolds what
happened in Vermont supports the worst
fears of many a sense that no place is
immune from the rising tide of hate
Jackson prco Global News Washington
police in Montreal are investigating
vandalism at a Jewish Community Center
early this morning a Molotov cocktail
was thrown through the glass door of the
Jewish Community Council Office nobody
was inside at the time but two liberal
MPS had been there hours earlier
discussing security concerns with Jewish
leaders police in Montreal have reported
an increase in hate crimes targeting
both Jewish and Muslim communities since
October the 7th a grieving family in BC
is going public with a plea to other
parents after what happened to their
12-year-old son Prince George RCMP say
their investigation revealed the boy
took his own life in response to sex
tortion as Angela Jung explains his
parents say they had no idea their son
was being
blackmailed he had the heart C no dry
eyes as Nicholas Smith thinks about her
12-year-old son Carson he was just he
was a happy all around kid
they say he was using SnapChat but they
had no idea he was being blackmailed
until it was too late sending pictures
um and being threatened if he
didn't give money or gift cards on
October 12th Carson took his own life
the RCMP investigation revealed Carson
was a victim of sextortion though the
investigation continues police have not
identified a suspect
now his parents are sharing their story
raising awareness of the dangerous
predators targeting youth I would want
every kid to know that it's okay don't
be embarrassed don't be scared come out
talk to somebody talk to a grown-up talk
to an adult talk to a counselor an RCMP
officer the people on the other end of
the chat are con artists and they're
incredibly good at what they do they
don't have emotion they don't have
feeling and all they want is to separate
the person they're talking to from their
money Amanda ta took her own life after
suffering in silence for years her
abuser was sentenced to 13 years behind
bars since Amanda's death law
enforcement agencies have seen an
increase in online sexual abuse the
majority of victims are boys between the
ages of 13 and 18 it is truly terrifying
to have this happen to you there's no
safe place there's nowhere to retreat
from these images and the harassment
that follows them Carson's family wants
victims to know there is hope talk to
somebody it's not as bad as it seems a
message they wish they could have told
their son Angela Jung Global News
Burnaby
BC a fourth person has died after a
shooting in a Downtown Winnipeg home
early yesterday morning and police say
no one has been
arrested this is a a dangerous offender
in my view and uh you know we must do
everything that we can to identify that
person and take them into custody police
were called to a Winnipeg home just
after 4: yesterday morning a man and a
woman were pronounced dead at the scene
another man and woman died in hospital
and a fifth person a 55-year-old man
remains in critical condition police are
asking anyone with information or access
to surveillance video in the area to
contact them Alberta's Premier makes her
move coming up how Danielle Smith
intends to push back against against the
federal government's proposed clean
electricity rules plus the powerful
storm pummeling War torn Ukraine and
Miriam Webster keeps it real with its
word of the
year if uh the federal government
doesn't back down you bet we are going
to find a way to get natural gas on
stream Alberta Premier Danielle Smith
has invoked her sovereignty act
legislation as she continues to push
back at the federal government over its
clean electricity regulations Heather
URI West explains how she intends to try
to get around ottawa's plans Alberta's
government is committed to protecting
albertans from federal overreach and so
for the first time since introducing the
controversial legislation last year
Alberta is invoking its sovereignty act
with a resolution calling ottawa's plan
to bring provincial electricity grids to
Net Zero by
2035 harmful to Alberta it asked cabinet
to order all provincial entities to
refrain from enforcing or complying with
the proposed Federal electricity
regulations but it doesn't stop there
because a sovereignty act cannot compel
private companies to break federal laws
Smith says the province will consider
setting up a crown corporation that
would invest and operate electricity
fired by natural gas for conservative
government that Champions private
Enterprise and limited government
interference it's a surprising step but
not enough to move the federal
environment minister to stand down we
will continue moving ahead with this uh
there is no legal basis for what Alberta
is is is is doing and we feel that we're
on very Solid Ground And the fact that
we already have some provinces who are
on board with us as well as a number of
private companies and investors who say
that this is the way to the Future it's
the kind of thing that will drive away
investment from Alberta in all sectors
of the energy economy The peman
Institute says according to its own
modeling Alberta could reach ottawa's
clean electricity targets without
compromising grid stability or
affordability but that's only if the
province's renewable energy sector which
has already been subjected to a
six-month pause is allowed to grow when
I talked to these companies and and uh
they're looking elsewhere right now we
hope that the federal government backs
down a game of chicken with Alberta's
electricity future in the balance
Heather urex West Global News Calgary
still ahead seeking Clarity on the
number of foreign workers at an Ontario
electric vehicle battery
[Music]
plant as the war in Ukraine rages on the
fighting has been Complicated by a
fierce winter storm hurricane force
winds heavy snow and flooding of Knocked
Out power to nearly 2 million people in
parts of Ukraine and Russia the storm is
hitting as tens of thousands of
Ukrainian troops stay on the front lines
fend off Russian forces there are fears
Moscow will Target Ukraine's power grid
in the winter months ahead an emergency
meeting was held in Ottawa today about
hiring practices at an electric vehicle
battery plant being built in Windsor
Ontario conservative MPS want the
federal government to release details of
the contract for the $15 billion project
because of conflicting information over
how many temporary foreign workers will
be employed Mackenzie gray explains
it's one of the biggest corporate
subsidies in Canadian history it'll
deliver for workers it'll deliver for
communities it'll deliver for our
economy $15 billion will be given to car
makers stantis and South Korean tech
company LG to build an electric vehicle
battery plant in Windsor Ontario but the
estimated 200 jobs created is now in
dispute after temporary foreign workers
have been brought in to get the plant
built fig figuring out how many has been
a challenge there's one temporary for
worker that's been approved for this
project we've only had less than a few
than 100 people that have come in anyone
who's guessing numbers they don't know
really what they're talking about you
have to talk to the engineers Windsor
Police had said it would be 1,600
workers but the final number is nearly
half that there will be 900 Korean
workers that will come in and help us
but there will be 700 Canadian trades
address some of the the uncertainty
leading the conservative to push for the
contract to be made public Canadians
deserve to know how their money is being
spent bringing specific people to Canada
with proprietary knowledge is not
unusual for auto projects this kind of
approach to launching uh Automotive
plants be they battery plants or
assembly plants is not new neither is
the Canada South Korea Free Trade
Agreement which allows companies like LG
to bring in South Korean laborers
without following temporary foreign
worker rules that's why we signed the
agreement originally to allow for that
but I think what complicates things is
the large amount of government funds
going to support the project once the
plant has been built there may be bigger
problems stellantis is CEO now saying
the electric vehicle market May soften
Donna with potential political and
Regulatory changes in the US and Europe
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa tonight
thanks next some of the wild and wacky
winners of this year's comedy Wild Life
photography
[Music]
award America's oldest dictionary is
getting real it's chosen authentic as
the 2023 word of the year as the line
between what's real and fake gets
increasingly blurred Miriam Webster says
there was a substantial rise in online
searches for authentic driven by
interests in artificial intelligence
identity and social media authentic is
defined as not false or imitation and
true to one's personality Spirit or
character other top searched words in
2023 are Riz short for Charisma plus
deep fake and
coronation and that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna freezen here's
something I learned in 2023 there are
comedy Wildlife photography awards it's
all authentic and the winner in 2023 is
this kangaroo jamming out on an air
guitar there are a lot of other funny
animal pictures too it's an antidote to
negative and depressing pictures of
Nature and the money from licensing
these images goes towards Grassroots
conservation organizations thanks for
watching
[Music]
bye-bye